[Musique]
la pollution et du ciel dégage des
quantités de produits chimiques de toute
nature dont une énorme quantité de gaz
carbonique et cette quantité de cet anti
munich se propage dans l'atmosphère
l'atmosphère et risque de faire date
master une espèce de st il ya aller
l'histoire du ch et aux deux ont ensuite
entendu ces erreurs ne fabrique beaucoup
mais une des y'a quand même des
correcteurs automatiques
[Musique]
d'où le tiroir en effet de serre général
réchauffement de 2 ou 3 degrés deux de
la température de l'atmosphère douce
fusion infusion d'une énorme quantité de
glace polaire aussi bien au sud qu'au
nord et glace de montagne et risque de
réchauffement donc à cause du
réchauffement de 3 degrés de moyenne
suffisent n'est ce pas est montée des
eaux est donc noyer noyade de toutes les
deux toutes les côtes basses jets de new
york est le havre et marseille et nice
et l'on nous agir print en train de
paniquer les populations là
[Musique]